go out there and there's no question
that there's evil in the world and I
think if we could see the evil that
really was around us we'd probably faint
with fright and I've met a lot of evil
people I've met a lot of dictators and
killers and seen a lot of death gone
into villages where people have been
mowed down i've been into those villages
a couple days later and vultures are
picking them your bones dry I've been a
lot of killers that you know it's
interesting some of them most evil
people nor can be very charming it's
interesting how charismatic they can be
and then there are some are just
strictly evil in Africa evil sometimes
can be almost you've almost cut it
because there's a lot of animist and
it's real I mean it's I mean things can
dance in the air I mean it's it's scary
it brings hair I mean your hair's pop up
it's so scary in America the evilness
that is here is sophisticated because
we're sophisticated you know surround us
is can is comes in through beauty and
things that that are false and stuff
like that but in some places you can cut
it with a knife it's black and white
that's evil you don't even have to think
about it it's real
very well
and how do you put it together with your
Christian faith in that I think that
Julius was Julius question was that
there's this good god in whom you
believe I think he put it's all right
Julia say that again there is this good
god in whom you believe but there's this
evil that's as thick that you can cut it
with with knife and it's pervasive well
I mean I think that I believe what the
scripture says is greater as he does in
you than is in the world and that you
need protection and that you need to put
on the armor and that you need to have a
prayer partner and God says when two or
more of you are gathered together in
prayer I'm there I will protect you and
you know this is not a perfect world we
live in a world that's rough and I lost
my son he died of leukemia and he was 12
and then he struggled had a bone marrow
transplant had a rare type of leukemia
and I've you know during those four
years and we didn't know whether he was
going to live or die and you know there
were times I felt that God was not awake
he was sleeping
but it's really interesting that when
that situation was over I fell in love
of God more than i did before my son got
sick I can't explain that to you now you
can go the other way to you can blame
God for everything and but this is an
imperfect world and we're going to go
through tough times you can do it with
God or you can do it without him but i
can tell you I've gone through some
tough times it's better to deal with him